have you dated a fan i was gonna ask you
would you go out with someone that's in
your messages no why not i don't think
so i feel like you're skipping five
steps they already like you first three
dates done what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine still up do we just become best
friends
hey everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters sophia and
sistine okay i don't know if you guys
have noticed but i have changed my look
we haven't
okay well um unfortunately i don't know
if anyone else has these moments but i
am about to go on a trip and for some
reason leading up to those days before i
leave i
barely sleep like i wake up in the
middle of the night and my brain goes
wait did i
do i need to schedule this appointment
did i get all my work done what do i
need to pack what do i need to buy no
i'm a super anxious child yeah me too
and i'm not one of those travelers and
you're the same way where we don't do it
last minute we like to have everything
done
the
night before or like two nights before
it's almost like you're more anxious
before the trip but and then right when
you get there you're like oh why did i
even stress out
about anything
always always and i'm trying to so i'm
headed to uh to new york and so i was
like okay you know what i'm gonna try to
do this very daunting task of not
packing a check check-in bag but like a
carry-on and seeing if i can fit new
york weather clothes
in a carry-on you just have to wear most
of it on the plane like wear four shirts
two jackets or boots on your feet boots
on your hands yeah right yeah honestly
just yeah that's perfect good idea wear
eight hats remember that episode of
friends where joey did that oh well it
was more just to get back at uh
his uh i think it was ross or something
and he started layering everything
i don't actually remember the plot say
she's not a true friends fan but the
reason why i said do i look different is
because at 4 30 this morning i just
could not fall asleep at all it was one
of those moments where i took extra
melatonin i tried doing yoga for like
three seconds i did yoga at 4 30 in the
morning i said three seconds i was
trying to just calm my brain or like
calm myself if i walked into your room
at 4 30 for some reason and just saw you
doing downward dog i would be like i
would have you know that feeling when
your parents walk in on you doing
sit-ups and you're like in middle school
and it's so weird it's like
it'd be like that moment i'm not one of
those people that randomly decide just
cut their hair like you've done it
scarlett's done it scott's really done
i've seen her suddenly have layers and
everything like that but i was like you
know what i've been watching a lot of
pam and tommy and i'm really loving
these updos that people have been doing
and i i really wanted it so i started to
try to cut it and you can kind of see it
it's not bad it's not that i mean this
side is way shorter than the left yeah
but that can be tweaked i just don't
trust anyone else to cut my hair anymore
i feel like i have ptsd from getting my
hair cut at the salon because you say oh
i just want an inch four inches later
you've got like a bob yeah wait this is
i this is definitely not for every
person in the world but i feel like when
guys cut my hair they cut a lot shorter
than when girls cut my hair but i also
feel like a female cuts male hair better
yeah i have felt like that too so maybe
i'm not saying by the way we're not
coming out for these male hair stylists
and they're like i can cut the best
while you're judging me but also i feel
like i've gotten a better blowout from a
man that's
so true tell me the science behind that
yeah where are we going with this i
don't know let's let's talk updates
sophia and i are moving into our new
apartment and eight days now i know
we're so excited we've been counting
down the days i am so excited to leave
the little rink dink yeah apartment
behind the panera it is the end of an
air i'm so excited just to shower and
not see brown water come out you know
what just have this for yourself don't
make your apartment your personality
trait it's not it's just well it's a
[ __ ]
we tried we just kept saying you know it
was really shitty and so broken right
now we have two microwaves and we could
see the inside of one of them yeah and
we just keep saying it has character no
it doesn't have character it doesn't
have if it was a character it would be
like a villain maybe the hunchback well
no what we were hoping for for character
we're like uh yeah we're gonna get a
wall that has all bricks and some cool
like maybe
open what what is it when the ceilings
have exposed pipes like post pipes new
york soho that's character you're not
gonna get that other than downtown l.a
we're not there so what we got is just
yeah okay hold on we did get exposed
pipes because there's a hole in our
ceiling there's a whole interesting leak
so technically we manifest that is true
we got that part and poisoning and leaks
and brown water and all the stuff but
we're finally really excited to move out
and it's funny because
i actually don't really know what
sistine's ordering and she doesn't
really know what i'm ordering but we
have completely different style types
you say that but i honestly think our
apartments are gonna look exactly the
same and that's what i'm really excited
about creating my own space that is just
me and it's everything that i like and
it's my routine um but what aesthetic
are you going for
i
want my apartment to look super super
super cozy i want a big couch fluffy
rugs like i want almost when you walk in
it's the warmest feeling ever like i
want to be
able to come back to a place where i
just feel calm like i hate when things
are too
stingy or there's like too much [ __ ]
everywhere like i don't mind adding like
succulents and things like little plants
but i don't like when it gets too
cluttered it's going to look like a
cloud yeah but i also don't like when it
looks too
white on every single countertop like
there's not even a i feel like the main
difference between yours and mine is i'm
gonna walk into a cloud of incense yeah
and can't breathe and then there's gonna
should be crystals everywhere sound
baths too she doesn't like oh my god
sophie's gonna do a sound bath if i hear
that from my room i'll be pissed
tell me how a sound bath is relaxing at
all it's supposed to help vibrate your
body into i don't know there's like some
actual sit in like a massage chair if
you want your body to try to have a
massage on the couch yeah because i
don't i don't get it honestly that for
me it's like a form of torture you're
sitting there not being allowed to move
and all you hear is the same
yeah i don't think my neighbors are
gonna like it but i'll definitely have
some like crystals and things like that
and maybe what is it what is it called
um a diffuser like an oil oh my god
diffuser i love that stuff i want i want
you to come in it smells like lavender
and you're instantly feeling like you're
at a spa so i think i'm sort of going
for the same aesthetic minus everything
you just said except for the the white
clean looking apartment that's what i'm
sort of going for although i did order
um
a family i thought it'd be so funny
family
[Laughter]
so we have like a small balcony that we
could put some patio furniture yeah
ordered a family from the black market
so i wouldn't be so lonely no i ordered
a family of uh garden gnomes i thought i
thought you're just saying like a family
of mice or no
the garden gnomes a family
but
but they're stripping in it someone is
moving and pulling out his pants also
our balconies can be totally different i
want i want to like i'm actually the
most excited to redecorate my balcony
why because i want to just i love when i
can we do we don't have a balcony at our
place and our what we see our view is
like some person screaming at us from
below
about how i don't know if he is right
above me i said she could spit on me if
she wanted to no
oh yes i can actually yeah i just
thought
you know we should hook a ladder from
yours to mine yeah yeah who's gonna
who's gonna make that truck you yeah i'm
right because i'm gonna be able to
coordinate that i'll probably slept but
this is i said this to steam
tell me this and this is so embarrassing
you know you're getting older is when
you actually enjoy furniture shopping
that is so when west dome and had a
president's day sale like we popped off
i was so excited lulu and george i'm
like i am i'm on these sites it's so
true because i remember a few years ago
when mom would show me all of the new
furniture she was buying for a house i
literally wanted to go into comatose
yeah i was so bored and now it's all i
have about 17 tabs open on my computer
of different furniture stores i'm
obsessed with it obsessed and then i
also another thing when i'm getting
older having like an 18 skincare routine
i love trying new skincare products
another thing of getting older um i
found a gray hair yesterday
and
i i was like this must be the lighting
it can't be gray i'm 23.
it was a gray hair it was actually gray
it was a gray
[ __ ] hair
you know i plucked that sucker right out
that never happened flushed it i never
want to see you that's so embarrassing
so embarrassing i was going to sharpie
it like this sharp pretty tight
thing it's so
yes
yes
well other than that um i am i just
mentioned i'm flying across the country
this week and it's going to be kind of a
pain why are you flying sofia
for fun with who
by myself you're flying for fun by
yourself yeah just going by yourself to
check out tiger square the eminem store
i think the listeners would agree with
me when we've gotten pretty close over
the past almost two years we really are
comfortable with each other
i think it's
kind of selfish to lie to the viewers
okay well i'm seeing someone over there
and it's nothing
solidified
at all
just
just seeing i love just checking you to
admit i hate it cause i don't like dude
that's nothing's happening okay whatever
but i am
going across the country again we are
just in florida so i literally got back
from florida
monday and now i'm leaving for new york
yeah thursday but i you know what i've
been where you've been i've flown to see
someone
except the one gag of flying to see
someone that you're still trying to look
cute for is how the hell are you
supposed to look good after a five and a
half hour flight yes and it really mind
boggles me because some people like my
mom comes off a long flight looking
fresh as a daisy hell like hella
beautiful so gorgeous curls perfect skin
perfect that's why i said hello
she said hello is that a san fran thing
or something no i don't know never been
so i don't know
but oh great i genuinely am like oh yeah
my skin let's just collect all of the
oils and dirty air let's just stick them
in my pores let's hair let's get more
greasy from sitting there doing nothing
i know and mom comes out i say mom i'm
like i don't really know how to come off
this flight looking halfway decent i was
looking up hacks you did not look up a
plain
how-to house yeah yeah uh what what do i
bring how do i look for fresh how do i
keep my hair i'm coming off this plane i
don't want to look like how i actually
look
my my go-to is just you got to bring a
baseball cap i do that hides fifty
percent of your face well so i was gonna
maybe wash my hair the night yeah i am
gonna wash my hair the night before put
it like just loosely curl it and kind of
have it in a bun and so then i just have
it smelling like i take it out it
actually look good skin wise i was just
going to bring like a little concealer
and some blush and make a mount
moisturizer yes
i think that's pretty much it like
deodorant hopefully yeah perfume i need
to smell good i mean plants are
manscaped you might need some ball dude
all right
nice
i don't really know how to answer yeah
sure i need some fall deodorant i'm
excited for you though i'm gonna miss
you it's kind of weird being apart from
you yeah i know oh
yeah no because i've had to deal with it
100 times with you and your boyfriend
i'm not saying he's my boyfriend by the
way i'm just saying it's
i love when you just keep talking
yourself into a hole
we're gonna cut this oh why i love it
okay but i'm gonna miss you it's gonna
be a lot of fun bring me back um some
street meat street meat what are you
talking about the i think what are they
called they're like the falafel guys you
can find them on
every other corner so i'll bring my
falafels for you you know what it's
alarming about those those street
vendors the food's actually really good
right
but where do they wash their hands
that's a good question because first of
all i've never seen street no no because
i probably won't go up and ask him so do
you wash your hands
before cutting these meats you know what
i told sophia she should do what go to
the museum of sex you did tell me that
that place is
magic i'm not a big museum goer but that
sign me up yeah at the end of the tour
it's a sex stop sex sex shop
that was just yeah butchered we make
unwaxed sex toys
i've been wanting this for so long are
you kidding me that's such a good idea
yeah would anyone use it out there let
me yeah would you just like i got one
not okay cool cool cool so let's just
jump into who we have on today we have
connor wood ak fibua he's a podcaster
he's a youtuber he's a tick talker um he
has brook and connor make a podcast i
think i got that and he's hilarious and
we're super super excited to have him on
i'm actually stoked to have a mom
because he is constantly on my 4u page
and you know what he's just here for if
you guys want to giggle if you want a
good laugh stay tuned
you're welcome
this segment of unfiltered finance is
brought to you by
moneyline what's moneyline not like we
haven't talked about it before but just
to remind you it's a financial app
that's full of innovative products to
help you own your money life you can
download it in the app store today and
don't wait because time is money people
speaking of money it's number one three
digits but it's got a huge impact from
everyday purchases to buying a house
yeah we are talking about
credit scores yeah yeah i know they're
not that's sexy but we gotta talk about
it i mean how scores work though they're
they're kind of sexy sophia do you think
so you're giving credit right right so
let's just get to the basics here so
what's credit score so basically it's a
number that determines how good your
credit is so this is a number that goes
from 300 to 850 and the higher the
better right and it gets a little bit
more complicated there's two types of
credit scores fico's the original from
1989 and vantage score which is the
newer one from 2006. there's three big
credit scores that use vantage score
equifax experian and transunion so it
kind of depends on what you're using
credit for because different situations
will use different types of scores but
that's getting advanced let's just keep
it simple for now so what's the perks of
having a higher credit score interest
interest interest you pay
less in interest when you have higher
score plus you qualify for better cards
with more rewards and points right so if
you want to use those points you got to
keep that score as high as you can the
lower your score is the less cards
you'll qualify for that sucks yeah and
it can make applying for a mortgage a
huge headache so the obvious question
here is how do you have or get a high
credit score it's a little bit more time
consuming than getting a high score in
candy crush but
it really all boils down to a few simple
facts but before we even do that you
need to know what's actually on your
credit report all right i'm down how do
i do that for someone who's never done
this before where do you even start
uh try google sofia but seriously let's
just walk through this so there's a
bunch of options to get a free credit
report you can really just google it and
i wasn't kidding about that when you get
the report it'll show how many lines of
credit you have open and how long the
accounts have been active your balances
and your score so that's the easy part
right so we can see it but let's talk
about improving it and it only comes
down to a few key factors payment
history credit usage age of accounts
credit mix and new credit inquiries okay
that is a mouthful but let's simplify
payment history is just what it sounds
like if you never really miss payment
pay early or on time and keep things
paid off it looks really good and i mean
really good right and you also don't
want to max everything out at once so
try to keep at least two-thirds of your
available credit open so keep the online
shopping in check i know that is easier
said than done but the age of accounts
is easier essentially the longer you
have credit the better it is for your
score lenders like to see that you've
managed your credit for a while it shows
responsibility as for credit mix and
inquiries it just means you want to have
a mix of different credit types credit
cards
personal loans mortgages etc and an
inquiry just means that you aren't
applying for new cards way too often so
that's a lot to keep in mind right but i
swear it gets easier as you go okay so
how do you know when you've made it how
do i know when i made it mm-hmm maybe
when the paparazzi starts all right all
right all right but seriously let's talk
good better best do you need an 850. if
you can get an 850 that's amazing go
off
but you don't need to have a perfect
score to have good credit though
anything above 670 can be considered
good credit and the average american has
around 700 scores so you don't need a
perfect credit to get a good score and
on the other side anything below 570
would be considered
not so good by the lenders but don't
worry because if you're down there you
can also raise that score up
and if you're intimidated by doing it
alone you can get help there are
programs like money lines credit builder
plus that can improve your credit while
you also save money right it's called a
credit builder loan these loans that are
essentially made up to help you improve
your score and build on-time payments
that will boost your score and you can
access a portion of that loan right away
cha-ching all right so i think we've
covered a lot of ground today but i'm
feeling good about this credit score
this has been unfiltered finance brought
to you by moneyline moneyline combines
motivation knowledge products and offers
a personalized app experience that helps
you own your money life every day
download it in the app store today today
you guys were so excited to have on the
hilarious youtuber tick tock star
podcaster connor with joining us aka
fibula hey a studio audience
yes
thank you so much i feel like i've seen
you so much on my phone oh
yeah yeah well ditto no that's a lie no
i i just finished up i was also kind of
late because i was watching your episode
from yesterday oh and i have a lot to
live up to that's why i tried to dress
cooler because of stephen oh yeah yeah
he's he's a great interviewee i was
pretty surprised by that too yeah yeah
and i'm trying to look as like chill and
laid back as him
i don't know if it's gonna happen do
tattoos yeah okay so there you go yeah i
do have where are your tattoos uh here
here so all that here
here okay so is there a reason why you
chose below the waist yeah because my
mom
because my mom because your mom would
kill me yeah you gotta interview still
you gotta get a job you do wear shorts i
do yeah so what if your job required
shorts
or are you going to wear your job like
i'm getting some concealer then i guess
at that point i i think this is a bad
stigma because i feel like we should
jump right in but
correct me if i'm wrong i feel like a
thigh tie is a frat boy move
yeah is it so did you get it while you
were in a fraternity no but um it was i
got it in someone's garage which is the
same exact thing i think it's doing it
yeah yeah why it was my friend launched
this magazine
and it was like kind of towards the tail
end of like locked down so like we were
all like vaccinated whatever and so we
went in and this guy was like i do
tattoos and i was like had a couple
drinks course of course i have an open
diet funny you say that what was the
drink that meant uh tequila of course
mule or something it was like sweet but
it's dangerous you couldn't really taste
it no of course not and then that's the
point you know one thing led to another
and i'm only underwear in a garage full
of people like this random girl is
holding my hand is that her i'm like no
it's hurt so bad it's so bad you gotta
get your time you're like oh they know
it feels good so good i'm crying because
there's so much something in my eye both
my eyes both my eyes what is it what's
on your thigh it says could be worse
and i would show you
just what i would have to take off my
pants well we are on wax and i think the
viewers would love to see well i also
have something else to admit i got
dressed in a rush after watching
steven's episode so i'm not wearing
underwear oh
yeah so i think that more than it being
like a willing and able it's more of
like a lawsuit situation i just feel
like it would be really great for
viewership but another time but maybe
maybe those are loose enough that i can
that's get up to can you oh no it's like
right away but i think it's so funny
that it could be worse it's kind of
ironic it so like it speaks for itself
exactly so when my mom saw it and i'm an
adult with a 401k she's still like i
feel like i'm losing control i'm like
well
i haven't lived with you in about five
or six years so yeah i think that that's
okay
would she be okay with any tattoo that
you get like that she would be oh you
know because it's my name or my birthday
oh do you have like mom with a heart and
she's like wait i love that one yeah i
think she would be like flattered
yeah something like that probably yeah
is there anything that you have on you
that you don't like no
yes i'm sorry yeah oh yes this one i'm
like
it's funny but i'm just like why did i
do that
i like it oh it matches your pants yeah
it's kind of why is that cool
all squiggly yeah so that's the reason
like i had this girl like a couple weeks
ago go like is that real and i'm like
yeah isn't it kind of she's like oh did
you get it on purpose oh no
well yeah because it's like it's i
didn't like fall asleep and accidentally
draw it on right on my knees
yeah it was such a weird and then she
was like okay this is my stop i'm
getting off and i was like way to
do a little sting and sting and leave
yeah this is a girl yeah dating no no
just like random girl in the elevator oh
oh oh that's kind of um is that better
or worse kind of just bold i actually
respect it yeah i was gonna say like
that's a very quick interaction for an
elevator yeah yeah all right right to
the point let's talk about how you
born in austin yeah and did you go to
school in austin as well i did yeah ut
austin oh my god
i was for a little bit and then dropped
and joined like a co-ed frat wait
there's a co-ed for us yeah it was new
um but i was like
like out of state so i didn't know
anybody and all of the out-of-state kids
were joining this thing
and it was like guys that i had met
while i was like rushing and everything
else so i was like oh yeah this seems
sick and it ended up being like i did
three years wait oh if it's a co-ed frat
do you guys live in the same house girls
and guys there was like an unofficial
house where like girls and guys would
live in i'll see i see the appeal now so
yeah of course yeah it's fun and it was
it was so fun i have like never made a
decision so correct than going to ut
awesome oh out of all the decisions that
was the best one that's the only good
decision i've ever made why did you
leave the frat i kind of like made
friends really quickly and then i had
made other friends
rushing other fraternities and i was
like
i can't really hang out with my other
friends because i'm doing this
and then that's kind of like this
unspoken rule you know it's like you
dirty rush you've had you met friends
and then you left and i was like right
right it's kind of a tough call but yeah
you see i gotta put me first i gotta put
me first see if i could do it over again
i would go to ut austin i've never been
to austin but it just looks like so much
fun yeah really the bar hopping the
music i just imagine everyone with big
blonde hair and cowboy boots and i'm
like this is where i want to be is any
of that accurate i know 100
oh great and that was culture shock
because yeah football obviously is like
big in texas and
like ut austin football is like die hard
like people are like
blood sweat tears for it right and so i
go to like my first game and i'm used to
going to games like here like usc like
you wear like board shorts and a jersey
or like a t-shirt yeah so i wore that
because it was 100 degrees out oh yeah
all of my guy friends were wearing
starch jeans and boots and button-up
shirt tucked in with like a belt and all
the girls for a football game proper
that's 100 degrees and all the girls are
wearing like direct like dresses boots
cowboy hat before like a stage coach are
we going to stagecoach like every day is
stagecoach yeah it's like nice i mean
that's for the game days yeah okay but
yeah i mean it's like how is like the
nightlife there is it where are you from
austin are you from i was born in austin
oh so you're kind of used to the like
the rhythm it goes on yeah how to go out
yeah the bars there is it more bars or
clubs or
um there's clubs but nobody really goes
to the clubs um and it's it's awesome so
there's a bunch of like try-hard places
right you know how in l.a there's a
couple places what's the johnny's place
and joey joey b's something like that i
feel like i know what you're talking
about but i
we don't ever go out so you're asking
the wrong people well i know i'm like
i'm talking about some place in west
hollywood i've never been but we know we
all we do we lived in los angeles we
live in west hollywood you know it's
like i guess it's like hollywood more
than
but it's the place where you walk
through the fridge
and you go into the oh oh oh oh oh you
know it
oh
employees
no vacation davey wayne's joey johnny
johnny
judy b jones
johnny do you like the milkshakes i
haven't been there in a long time so
it's like try hard everything in austin
it's like
we're going to this bar tonight it's at
the top of a parking garage you climb
under a ford explorer
it's like the most absurd like they try
so hard to
but it's fun it's really cool but like
everyone's trying to like out instagram
each other for like cool bars right and
all the bars i went to school with like
my one dollar beer wednesdays are being
torn down
to build
it's crazy it's kind of nice because
like you think of the place you went to
school yeah and then like i go back now
and i'm like i don't even miss it
because it doesn't even look like my
college yeah it's like okay cool now i'm
just visiting austin so when did you
move to l.a three years ago now do you
prefer los angeles over austin i don't
really know
i don't really know it's hard here yeah
it's different i feel like the bars are
better like here where you're living now
and that yeah where you're living right
now but but in terms of dating i guess
yeah are you having an easier time in
austin or here
um i mean you guys know this like once
you
you have to literally meet somebody now
like i i was on dating apps and stuff
before
and you know like a couple matches here
and there and then then tick tock blows
up or whatever and it's like oh now i
have 50 plus likes that i have to go
through
people like me for my personality not my
face or like i'm just sure that's a joke
um
did you were you on all of the apps or
were you on like just a few of them um
so i worked at bumble that's so i
graduated i was interning at mumble
before graduation and then i just took a
full-time role there
really early when it was like a startup
that's not like a flex to be on the
bumble app saying like i work here well
that was another thing it was like
my job is in my bio and people were like
i'm looking for a job post grad and it
was in austin so it was like like these
girls were like i need an internship and
i was like oh like do you want to get a
coffee first
and i'll look at your resume
wait so is bumble something you have to
pay for there's like premium just like
so you could be like i could give you
premium
premium right
oh my god what did you learn from
working at bumble because sophia and i
have you know had our fair share of
dating apps yeah and um didn't work no i
don't think they were sorry yeah but
i've heard some success stories like
katie austin yeah she met her boyfriend
oh that's true on a dating app so what
have you found like what is the secret
sauce from working there yeah your
profile i think i mean unless you're
supposed to be like a normal cool person
right no one yes okay that's number one
you have to be normal okay and like you
know fun whatever but like the build of
your profile is so key like if you if
your first picture is a picture of just
you and you're smiling like with teeth
yeah your matches go up like
sixty-five well i'm really out oh yeah
i have never ever smiled with my teeth
in a photo you are like a soft smiler no
not even i honestly i i
i practice in the mirror smiling with my
teeth and i think i look horrendous i'd
rather
yeah that's great it's a smile
unapproachable well i mean they they
just had like actual scientists come in
and like analyze the data
with these problems you would do in
another life be a scientist that would
analyze that data yeah okay so i said on
the last episode i'd be a doctor and
they thought that was funny but i think
i would be a really good analyst like i
would be really good
are you laughing because i said i wanted
to be a doctor too no no no no no no i'm
sorry
i breathed in some kombucha like and i
was like am i about to throw up on this
podcast
um no that would be awesome thank you i
don't even have an idea of what i would
be because
i haven't held a job for more than like
a year fired from jobs just yeah oh
why um i don't know i mean like things
change or whatever but like that was so
vague i'll tell you that
no i mean it was nothing bad but so the
whole build of the profile if you're
smiling in your first picture
you boost by like 60 like more matches
or swipe rights i guess
and then like if you have a picture with
your friends yeah people like because
you can tell someone has friends how
about with a dog or a baby dog baby
family what about bikini yeah well i
mean for girls they there's there's a
thing with like i can't remember the
science behind that or the numbers
behind having a bikini photo in the
first picture but it was less than just
having a face with smile yeah what about
a guy wearing a bikini yeah personality
personality that's not a personality i
feel like i feel like there's a
difference between being funny and being
too funny like try harder try hard well
is he in cabo yes you know like you know
there's there's yeah there's something
like that on your profile yeah so i
deleted cents oh so you're not on any no
so we're people i just got onto raya too
and i was like this is just not even
weird right it's strange strange raya
and the league don't really or no do you
think they put you in a different
category it took me two years to get on
so i don't know what category
finally do that a lot of those apps do
that where they kind of i don't know if
bumble does but i know that ryan because
i've seen my friends go on ride and some
of them have completely different
options than what i would have or like
really she would have yeah really yeah
i've seen it
i don't know i don't like right first of
all you can't screenshot
and they keep threatening to they did
used to threaten to kick me off and do
it or airplay you can't air play because
i like to include
well
what we would do is when she had a hinge
for a hot second we would airplay it to
the tv and we'd have my entire family
sitting on the couch and we'd all be
like yeah it's game night no it was game
night it was so much fun yeah
so you don't so you're not on anything
but i feel like because he's on raya
yeah but not really right you're not
active i i got on but i'm not like i
actually genuinely don't know how to use
it like i tried to push a couple buttons
and i was like oh you're not really
making it what song did you use for your
rod i didn't know you put a song in your
eye that's the whole thing it's a
slideshow very sociopathic movie damn no
music maybe that's why just photos but
the song the song is honestly when i was
on it is what changed my mind because if
it's really funny like i did um the
theme song from halloween kills so it's
like doo doo doo doo doo
well i didn't think about it like that
that makes more sense but you got to put
a song on it yeah okay well lesson
learned i think i would put
all i want to do is have some fun by
sheryl cruz all i want to do is win by
dj that's going to be a good one too
all i want to do is get a match match
match oh how are you just doing your own
version yeah
i think voice notes the integration
voicemails has been like the funniest
the funniest thing ever yeah hey we were
saying hate a voice now
we have voice notes like
being sent them but i think on the
profile it's such a huge personality
piece yeah oh for sure yeah i feel like
the why it's funny is because a lot of
people are so bad at it
like a lot of people you don't it's kind
of awkward like well how do you answer
something and if you're not naturally
funny you're trying to be funny
just do you avoid those
therapy i i don't know like
you can't learn funny you can't learn
funny we were saying that in the last
episode that it is so hard to find funny
people today i remember that
yeah he is a listener but okay so say
hypothetically or realistically if
you're going out with a girl do you look
for funny
i don't look for funny like i feel like
it just comes like yeah like i think
steven was saying too like if you try
too hard it's like an ick yeah yeah but
do you from your experience of dating do
you meet a lot of funny girls so you're
like i'm just always the funnier one in
the relationship or do the girls try to
be funnier with you because they know
that like oh you're woody i've been
funny girls
yeah i ha i have
and like a lot of times it's so weird
when i like do bits on tick tock yeah i
like do like stand up essentially and
i'll go to these girls and they're also
doing stand up and i'm like this is like
absurd kind of like it's almost like you
kind of have can't have two
people like
like competing almost dropping each
other like how do you how do you have a
conversation when you're all can you
just trying to drive the entire time i
don't know i don't know
i don't have the answer you get
exhausted after the date you're like oh
burn out yeah because it was like a two
hour stand up i'm like i need to go hang
out with my friends yeah and like
recharge oh yeah yeah and not talk to
anybody no you know what but i i think
your tick tocks are so funny and unique
and i'm surprised you're not 10 times
bigger than you already are oh thank you
you're very nice no you're very welcome
what made you start doing tick tock um i
got laid off my job oh is that what the
transition was because you were like i
got fired oh yeah well i mean i i so i
left bumble and went to bird scooters
and started the marketing team at bird
because it was also a new company that
became fully obsolete when nobody could
go outside or touch something that
everyone else is touching right during
the pandemic so it was just like
a matter of time and so like half the
company got
canned but uh and then i moved down to
newport beach for like a year and oh i
forgot that i was thinking i'm sorry i
think you were gonna like chime in i
forgot there's no mic over there she
probably wants to yeah yeah go ahead say
something about newport beach
i didn't know that yeah i was down on uh
the peninsula but i moved down to
newport for a while and then i was
living with my friends like my actual
like close friends not like yeah that
also all got laid off or weren't working
and we always said we were like are we
actually funny are we just so stupid
like i say that about myself all the
time i think i'm the funniest person
ever but no one seems to agree with me
no no he's saying that are we just being
like no like you're funny but you don't
you're like i don't know if this is
funny to other people well we never i
mean we never knew we were i wasn't
posting stuff online to be for like
views at that point i was just like
filming us being like idiots and we're
busting out laughing and i'm like we're
always like we need our own tv show but
i'm like no we don't no we don't we're
like we think we're funny
so what do you think made your tick tock
though different from everyone else's
because i think that i mean obviously
you're unique like you do different
content from everybody else but what do
you think what made yours stand out then
i think like for a lot of people i feel
like the algorithm just kind of
picks people and it's your lucky day and
then if it changes your life then it you
get you're just like i can answer that
question for you yeah
please not here you're him
no i think you stand out because when
you're
posting a tick tock a lot of people that
are trying to be funny they're literally
looking in the camera doing a bit that
is so rehearsed yet yours seems so
organic like you're funny within a
conversation that you don't it's almost
like you're giving a different pov to a
conversation do you know what i'm trying
to say
it's so interesting hearing you say that
like from
because i try to make it like i don't
write anything down it's conversational
yeah so like if i have a thought i'm
like okay try to get this out without
saying um and like 15 times you can get
it in in 60 seconds but like and then
sometimes it hits and sometimes it
doesn't but yeah the stream of
consciousness is what i was that was
always my goal to make it like very
natural and you can also tell on the
internet like is this person
really really trying are you like cut
from the same clock yeah thank you
that's so nice it's so nice refreshing
dude
i remember what it was because emma
chamberlain liked it oh no way yeah
and now you made it big when emma likes
it yeah yeah and i i didn't have any
followers and
so you know when like you see that first
like blue check you're like oh who is
this i didn't know who she was but then
i like asked my friends i was like who
is this and they were like holy smokes
and then i was like it was a video where
i was saying like everyone's saying like
be positive be positive it's like not
working so bad vibes only [ __ ] you like
somebody oh sorry that's fine that's
fine oh no rehearse you you know when
you like start posting and it kind of
starts to climb and then you get one i
think that one got 40 000 views but i
remember it as like one of my biggest
because it felt so big at that time
i'm following you right after
immediately oh my god most random things
yeah even on instagram like i'll see
something that's i like but follow the
person yeah
it's like one viral video yeah you get
like 10 000 followers it's almost like
not reflective of success because
someone can have a video that gets
that's hilarious but not intentional
yeah and so it can get 25 million views
and then they end up with half a million
followers and then can't recreate that
so like they have this
disparity of like views versus followers
like yeah
it doesn't add up but it is like
interesting are you doing tick-tock
full-time now yeah so
what would you say is your job title
it's tough i still do like i still do
other projects on the side of course i
advise for some tech companies because i
do like
particularly what is your profile on
write essay
i don't know
i need to read down pull it up pull it
up download it again it's your first
photo a smiling photo yeah i think so i
have a question
if someone called you a content creator
is that an insult
no okay i'm trying to make it myself
something that i can say out loud yes
because that was like
cringy cringey but it's not cringe
because it's actually a lot harder than
people think yeah yeah it works here but
like everyone here is a creator yeah so
it's like
i'm an advisor and consultant that's
what it says no i'm like that's what i
that's what i usually say i was like
that's kind of cool though advisor and
consultant um then all of a sudden they
look you up and you have like this
massive tick tock following that's kind
of cool that is it is kind of cool the
guy at whole foods
just a second ago and i was there was
like yo i like your pants
i
like clothes a lot like i was like oh
cool let's follow each other and then it
was just like a and he was like oh [ __ ]
and i was like yeah
like i don't know what to say have you
is it weird when people approach you and
they know who you are do you still no do
you get confused because when people
approach us we still get confused no i'm
gonna get off my phone sorry um i asked
you to pull it up i have such bad adhd
it's like actually insane i would have
forgotten what we were talking about i
can't text and talk at the same time oh
i'll start saying what i'm texting out
no i think
a lot of people come up and i think
that's good because it's just like
approachability and i hope that
that's what i'm conveying
online too it's like fun and have you
dated a fan i was gonna ask you would
you go out with someone that's in your
messages no why not i don't think so i
feel like you're skipping five steps
they already like you first three dates
done i know i have i'm i just got a new
therapist that i need to talk to that
that part over with right where it's
like what's your hesitation it's like
something about someone like liking you
yeah and i'm like okay what's wrong with
someone like i want to like like you
want to be organic first or like yeah
like not have it be like you know
because i don't want like my first
impression of someone being like
my videos online have you dated someone
that you didn't realize was a fan of
yours i've gone on dates yeah how was
that was it awkward no it was actually
really good oh so maybe you guys are
right yeah maybe we just had our first
breakthrough session
to figure out type no yeah like why are
you single yeah um i'm really like
what's wrong with you yeah yeah yeah
you're welcome full clothes you're funny
you're good at tick tock working tech
you're cute what's wrong with
thanksgiving thank you you forgot that
part i was like maybe they'd say like
that was for you to say oh
she's pulling me in with her eyes yeah
oh
we love that called out no i i told you
guys i can't even remember to blow out a
candle like yes texting people back is
hard for me oh so you're a bad texter
i'm like working on that you know it's
like it's it's i think it's a mature
thing a maturity thing people when
they're like i'm bad at texting i'm like
you just don't want to text me i'm very
texting yeah it's tough i mean right now
how many messages do you have let's look
oh god this is gonna go i think it's i
open all my messages 484 unread
yeah wait and i have one that i was
typing out it's adhd i'll start i'll
respond in my head
or like something will stress me out to
respond to you know are you one of those
people that'll type a message forget to
hit send so that i'm on the receiving
end with the bubble for two days i'm
like right now there's a message typed
out that i was typing and that's crazy
in the lobby and forgot to send oh
that's cool i think that's good it keeps
them on their toes yeah they're gonna
think about you for the next like two
hours oh yeah so that's a good dating
hack manipulation game that is actually
do you like the games
um
yeah i guess kind of that's what i was
saying like not to do the hot or not bit
on
you guys but
i was
saying like when someone likes me first
i kind of like the chase more like does
this girl hate me right right like
that's more attracted to me than a girl
being like directing you you're like
yeah and i shouldn't say that because
now i'm gonna get a bunch of dm's that
are like [ __ ] you no
by the way no it's all in good it's all
in good fun my dad says the same thing
he goes the chase is the most exciting
part of the relationship i like the
chase too it's the tug and pull but then
there's a fine line of when you've gotta
you know bring it out and bring it up
totally bringing it in right okay where
can people find your podcast podcast is
anywhere podcasts can be heard okay and
memorize that little line good uh itunes
spotify what day of the week do you put
it out thursdays so it'll be out
tomorrow i came from the studio just now
look at you double puff yeah oh yeah
it's so much easier right now than at
8am it is definitely this has been so
much of an easier talking situation it's
a good time um and your tick tock tick
tock is fibula we didn't even ask you
why your name yeah why is your name
fibula we kept saying the song by hannah
montana like my body's many farts you
guys oh yeah yeah people always used to
make videos with that is that the reason
why and tag me
no and this is going to be really weird
and i've been trying to make up a better
story because it's really confusing but
from austin my friends and i always went
to acl like like been like 15 years and
it's austin city limits a festival and
they would always try to get us through
i used to have that like the justin
bieber swoopy hair good for you yeah oh
yeah it was the days but
we they would like be like oh like move
and move we need to get a picture with
him and i would stand in the middle of
the crowd and everybody would move and
10 of my friends would come and take
pictures with me and everyone would be
looking like who is it who's that they'd
be like oh he's on disney channel he's
on wizards of waverly place
and i was like
and we would scoot our way through the
fronts people would move thinking i was
like from wizards of waverly places so
genius people will believe anything if
you have confidence yeah so we did that
for years and then like finally i was
like i should be getting like some
instagram followers out of this because
people would be like what's your
instagram and i would have to like spell
out my first and last name
and then they could look it up so i was
like this is so shady but
i couldn't find a one word thing and i
think i was in anatomy at the time and i
like like typed in fibular randomly and
it was open
and took it and it kind of rolls off the
tongue a little bit it doesn't work it's
really cool yeah i like it a lot and
then fibs is so my nickname all through
college and now it's like fibs
which is like a liar yeah so it's not
great but
it's what's fibula short for you like
connor
little white liar
a little liar okay so your tick tock is
fibula and your instagram is also
favorite instagram is also fibula tic
tocs two a's and so it's twitter it's
two days it's a fancy guy over here oh
yeah well thank you so much for coming
on this thank you guys for having me
this was a blast you guys too he's just
as cool as he looks right now this
outfit so happy to finally meet you and
thank you guys for sticking around for
this week's episode of unwaxed we will
see you next tuesday bye
[Music]
you